US INTELLIGENCE EXPERTS SAY FIGHTING IN UKRAINE IS
EXPECTED TO SLOW IN THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS BUT NOT END, OF COURSE.
UKRAINIANS ARE STILL BRACING FOR
NEW ATTACKS ON THE ENERGY GRID
AS TEMPERATURES DROP.
RUSSIAN TROOPS ARE FOCUSSED ON
THE EASTERN DONETSK REGION.
WILL RIP LILEY JOINS US FROM A B
SHELTER IN KYIV, UKRAINE.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAD TO GO TO
SAFETY THIS MORNING?
>> Reporter: YEAH.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY THE
ASSESSMENT HERE IN UKRAINE.
AND CERTAINLY WHAT WE ARE
EXPE
EXPERIENCING RIGHT NOW WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING.
LET ME LAY OUT WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING.
WE HAVE A LIVE POSITION TOWARDS
THE TOP FLOOR OF THIS HOTEL
LOOKING OUTSIDE.
WE HEARD THE AIR-RAID SIRENS GO
OFF, FOLLOWED BY REPORTS OF
POTENTIAL INCOMING RUSSIAN
MISSILES, A LARGE AMOUNT, DOZENS
OF MISSILES INCOMING HEADED IN
THIS DIRECTION.
SO WE AND ALL OF OUR STAFF HAVE
MOVED DOWN TO THE BOMB SHELTERS
UNDER GROUND.
ADJACENT TO AN UNDERGROUND
PARKING LOT.
SO THEY CONVERTED THIS AREA BUT
IT'S REINFORCED WITH CONCRETE,
SAFE TO BROADCAST FROM HERE AND
NOW WE WAIT FOR INFORMATION OF
WHAT MAY BE HAPPENING.
THE LAST ATTACK THAT HAPPENED 12
DAYS AGO, RUSSIA LAUNCHED MORE
THAN 70 MISSILES AND THE
UKRAINIANS SHOT DOWN MORE THAN
50 OF THEM.
A HIGH SUCCESS RATE.
BUT STILL AROUND 20 OF THOSE
MISSILES HIT THEIR TARGETS AND
THOSE TARGETS UNFORTUNATELY THE
CIVILIAN POWER INFRASTRUCTURE
THEY'VE BEEN REBUILDING TRYING
TO GET THE LIGHTS AND HEAT BACK
ON FOR PEOPLE ACROSS UKRAINE IF
WE ARE ON THE FRONT END OF
ANOTHER ATTACK OR THE ATTACK
COMES LATER IT'S BAD NEWS FOR
FAMILIES STRUGGLING WITH
TEMPERATURES PLUNGING HERE.
IN UKRAINE, WINTER IS COMING.
IN THE CAPITAL, KYIV, THE
FOREIGN MINISTER WARNS SNOW
WON'T BE THE ONLY THING FALLING
FROM THE SKIES.
>> WE ARE ANTICIPATING ANOTHER
MASSIVE MISSILE ATTACK BY
RUSSIA.
AND THE GOAL OF THIS ATTACK IS
TO BRING TOTAL DESTRUCTION TO
OUR ENERGY SYSTEM.
>> Reporter: CREWS ARE RACING TO
RESTORE POWER.
THESE TENTS SET UP BY THE
GOVERNMENT, A BADLY NEEDED BREAK
FROM THE BITTER COLD.
AT THIS FAST FOOD PLACE, BRAVING
BELOW ZERO TEMPERATURES AT THE
OUTDOOR GRILL KEEPS THE DOORS
OPEN WHEN THE LIGHTS ARE OFF.
SOME CUSTOMERS SAID THEY ONLY
WANT TO COME WHEN THERE'S NO
POWER BECAUSE THE FOOD TASTES SO
MUCH BETTER.
WE'RE JUST UKRAINIANS SHE SAID,
THAT'S OUR SECRET INGREDIENT.
ANOTHER SECRET FOR SURVIVING
DARK TIMES, CANDLES, A GOOD CRY,
AND PRAYER.
>> WHEN YOU COME HERE, WHAT DO
YOU PRAY FOR?
>> Reporter: WE PRAY FOR PEACE,
FOR THE WAR TO BE OVER SHE SAID.
DESCRIBING THE HARDSHIP OF LIFE
WITHOUT ELECTRICITY.
THEN I COME HERE AND REMEMBER
HOW MUCH TIME WE SPENT HIDING IN
BASEMENTS.
HIDING FROM RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WHO
OCCUPY AND TERRORIZED THEIR
DOWN.
BUCHA, THE SITE OF WHAT UKRAINE
CALLS UNSPEAKABLE WAR CRIMES.
>> IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED HERE, THIS COULD BE ANY
CHURCH IN ANY QUIET KYIV SUBURB.
UNTIL YOU LOOK AND SEE THE
BULLET HOLES.
>> A CLUSTER BOMB.
>> BULLET HOLES IN HER
CHILDREN'S BEDROOM WINDOWS.
AFTER LIVING THROUGH THE RUSSIAN
OCCUPATION, SHE CAN HANDLE
LIVING WITHOUT POWER.
>> WHAT IS REAL PROBLEM IS OR IS
NOT ELECTRICITY.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONNECTION.
SO I HAVE KIDS, IF SOMETHING
WRONG I CANNOT CALL TO THE
HOSPITAL AND CALL EMERGENCY.
>> Reporter: SHE TELLS ME WHEN
THE POWER GOES OUT, SHE LOSES
CELL PHONE SERVICE AND INTERNET.
BUT THEN --
>> OH MY GOD, IT'S MIRACLE.
>> IS THAT THE LIGHTS COMING ON
NOW?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: THE FIRST PLACE SHE
GOES, THE KITCHEN.
>> COFFEE, THAT'S YOUR NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY?
>> MY NUMBER ONE.
>> Reporter: SHE'S GRATEFUL FOR
THE LITTLE THINGS IN LIFE.
>> IT'S A MOMENT OF HAPPINESS.
>> GRATEFUL JUST TO BE ALIVE.
>> Reporter: YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
THE SENTIMENT WHEN PEOPLE ARE
LIVING FOR THE LAST NINE MONTHS
UNDER THE CONSTANT THREAT OF
RUSSIAN MISSILES RAINING DOWN ON
THEIR HOMES.
THE AIR-RAID SIRENS GO OFF SO
MUCH THEY'RE IMMUNE TO IT BUT
THIS TIME, THE REPORTS, A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN UKRAINE HIDING IN
THEIR BASEMENTS WONDERING IF THE
LIGHTS ARE GOING TO BE KNOCKED
OUT AND WHEN THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
DO THINGS THAT WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED LIKE HAVING A HOT CUP OF
COFFEE AT THEIR HOUSE.